- Well, the job you're best
known for, obviously, is SNL.
So what do you miss about the show?
- I miss so much about it.
I miss the people.
I truly miss the immediacy
of coming up with a joke
on Monday, spending 20 hours not sleeping
with friends who haven't slept either
and making up dumb jokes,
and then putting it on television
at the end of the week.
And having everybody see
it, that, I miss that.
I miss the immediacy of,
like, ooh, I got this idea.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then it being.
- [Kelly] Then it comes
to fruition very quickly.
- On live television on the show
you always wished you were on.
- Yeah, at the same time though,
'cause I've known a couple of
people that have hosted that,
and the hours that y'all keep are insane.
- Yeah, truly insane.
- Like, I don't like, do you sleep?
- Then, no.
I mean, well, it depends.
Some weeks, yes.
Some weeks, you're depressed and sleeping
'cause you're not in the show.
And then some weeks, and then some weeks,
you can't think because
you're in everything,
and then some weeks, same thing,
but then the second the show
starts, it all gets cut, and -
- [Kelly] That happens?
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Yes.
- That sounds stressful.
- It was very stressful.
- I know, I always thought,
because I've performed on it,
and I always thought, oh my gosh.
So what happened to like
three or four of those skits?
They're just like gone.
And I'm like, well,
all that work is like -
- My first show, I
remember they did, like,
a Justice League sketch with Mike.
It was Michael Phelps was
the host, and he was Aquaman.
And the whole joke was
they were telling him
that they were firing
him because they didn't,
he didn't really do much.
And it was a really funny sketch, but,
and it was this beautiful thing.
Everyone full costume, superheroes,
they built the Hall of Justice,
and they're like, that's cut.
And I'm like, that's a
house. That cost a house.
- Now, I know, and I'm going to tell you,
there is, I wish I remembered the skit,
but there was this one thing I saw
when I was performing there,
And I was like, that was my,
one of my favorite things that happened
'cause I was there the whole day.
I could see the whole
show and the rehearsal.
And I was like, why, who got rid of that?
I was so mad about it,
and I'm not even involved.
But I was like, that was so funny.
- I can't believe you've never hosted.
You're hilarious.
- No.
- People are like, you should host.
- Oh, I can't believe I host a show.
I never, oh, no,
I literally, I used to say no to, like,
saying, "And the award goes to."
Like, I would be terrified
to read a teleprompter,
cut to now.